Yep, good morning, folks.
Any people who have, yeah,
good morning to you.
Good morning, sir.
Anybody wants to bring up any point at 0
up, please put up your hand.
Good morning, sir.
Good morning, Gurdeep. Yeah, Gurdeep,
you don't have access to Taxila.
Sir, actually,
like before accessing Taxila,
it is asking us to select the examination
center. No, actually, I'm based out of...
Yeah, yeah, I can understand.
I am based based out of Switzerland and
it is not giving me the option to select
the correct option, sir,
so that is why I'm a bit stuck over there.
I understand.
And this is happening for the last two
days, I guess.
Yes, that's right.
Because I know that because of other
people knowledge which I acquire from
others,
this is not a process with which I'm
attached. But in any case,
I've heard from other students that
You,
they have asked for examination centres
two days back.
And why are you not being allowed to
select your examination center?
I am being only shown the centres in
India. Like I said,
I am deputed in Switzerland currently.
And for international locations,
Yeah, that I can understand.
the mode it is already showing is on site,
but accordingly I'm not able to proceed
by without choosing any centre of Indian
center.
So it is mandatory asking me to choose a
center,
Oh, good.
but I cannot choose a centre based out in
India and or the other overseas
designated centres which are not because
there is no centre as such of Bits Fulani
in Europe.
So that is why I am unable to proceed,
Okay.
sir.
I think the international centres are
mostly in the Gulf.
And that, that's right.
Okay.
I have written to the WILP support also.
Support,
see the where I forwarded your e-mail,
Yeah.
the more powerful location.
Okay, sir.
It is normally seen by the examination
department.
You can follow up on that particular meal.
Okay.
Sure, sir, okay.
And which means that this week's quiz you
will not be able to attend.
That, that's unfortunately is.
I listen to this.
Yeah,
so what I can do is there is a very
special case if you let me know by
Thursday.
Mhm.
that you're still not being able to
activate, I'll extend it for everybody.
Okay, sir.
I never take action for individuals.
After Saturday,
Yeah, yeah, that's okay, sir.
I cannot take action because once the
quiz is closed, it's closed.
It can't be open.
The only redeeming features that...
But you know,
you have to appear for only 8 quizzes.
And what I can do is instead of 14,
I can even have 15 if there are too many
Mhm.
people who have a problem. You know,
in between I can have a special quiz for
Oh.
people.
But I cannot open up a quiz that is
closed. All right.
And do follow up on that REDDY link,
OK, so yeah.
which I have forwarded to the examination
department.
Definitely, though.
Now that I've understood your case,
I will try to put it on to some
individuals.
I know a few people being an alumni of
BITS, many of these people, you know,
interacted with in the course of time.
But otherwise, normally,
it's people who are on campus faculty,
Okay.
that also the Pilani campus or the
Hyderabad campus.
Mhm.
They sometimes, if they take the trouble,
they can walk down and talk to the admin
people. Otherwise,
BITS is totally process oriented.
Every little thing, setting the exam,
evaluating the exam, taking the class,
handling the lab,
everything is a separate process and
coordinated only by a certain central.
People, OK,
Chik and GUDIYA have understood,
and you are up in the middle of the night
to talk about this.
Yes,
I have to attend early morning classes.
Yeah, go back to sleep here.
You can see the recording, I guess. Yeah,
Thank you, sir. Thank you. Thank you, sir.
Bye, sir.
OK. Bye, bye, bye. OK. Hi, Saranya.
Tell me.
Good morning, sir. Sir, actually,
this is my first lecture.
Good money.
I joined late this course,
and I have written you also about the
OK.
quiz one, quiz two. So I couldn't, I mean,
quiz three, or I started with quiz three,
that was only enabled for me. So just,
I don't know whether you got a chance to
Yeah.
No, no, no. See, I see these emails,
but once I get into a habit of replying,
see my e-mail.
individually people start expecting
individual replies. My thing is,
you catch me in the beginning of the
class, that's the best time. And you know,
we don't play ping pong. On mail,
it's just ping pong. See,
I've just explained to Gurdeep,
and you have to appear for only 8 quizzes.
Okay.
And somebody who's trying to be very
nicky-picky about it and say, no,
if I appear for more quizzes,
I can increase my scores. Not really,
because, you know,
8 quizzes getting averaged.
So even if you score 2 marks more in one
particular quiz,
that two marks get divided by 8 and
become 0.25. And in any case,
your marks are
I round them upwards before submitting it
to bits. So if your aggregate comes to 14.
25, I'll make it 15. So that is why,
you know,
I've got some feedback about people with
a given question. You know,
this particular question,
I would like to understand.
We simply don't have the time to try to
understand individual questions. Okay.
And you missed one or two quizzes.
You can miss up to how many quizzes?
Six quizzes and still be okay.
So I'll just request you to bear with me
and manage with the remaining quizzes,
okay?
Okay. Okay. Thank you.
Yeah, thanks so much. Thank you,
thank you,
thank you for being that cooperative.
You know,
I give the quizzes basically for people
to touch the course.
It's nothing more than that.
People are using ChatGPT, Gemini,
God knows Claude, to answer it.
But even that's okay with me because...
For 5 minutes people think about this
course that you think about me for 5
minutes, I'll go to heaven. Okay.
Thanks so much.
Anybody else so that we can otherwise we
can get clicking.
OK, we move with the course today.
You know, from this class on,
I will do a little bit of review of some
previous classes just to have you.
come up to pace,
things that I consider important.
So today I will be doing a little bit of
review on quality attributes.
Let me open today's slide and then
proceed.
So when I open the slides here,
two things happen.
One is that the slide gets automatically
uploaded into the SharePoint in MS TEAMS.
So you can download it if you feel like.
The other thing that happens is that
while I'm taking the class and you find
me too boring, you can go forward,
backward on the slides and
keep taking a look at them so you don't
have to get stuck with the slide I get
stuck on.
So there's a little bit of a mix up with
the course handout.
Yeah, just a sec.
So...
There's a bit of a mix up between CS4,
CS5, architecture design,
architecture significant requirements.
I'll go through that also a little bit.
These are small slide sets,
but we need to understand them properly.
So while I'm doing whatever I'm doing,
you can just take a look at these things.
With.
Okay, so...
We talked about architecturally
significant requirements,
but we'll touch on them a little further
today.
But before that,
I'm going to just talk about...
A few things about quality attributes.
And...
Let's talk about...
architectural design decisions. You know,
they are architectural design decisions.
So the first architectural design
decision we talked about was allocation
of responsibilities.
So,
what is the allocation of
responsibilities?
You identify system tasks and assign them
to modules, components,
or runtime elements.
You have to assign every task somewhere
to a module, to a component,
to a runtime element.
We call that allocation of
responsibilities.
This is the decision taken by an
architect. So you want to send...
e-mail, how should it be sent?
An e-mail can be sent directly by calling
your.
Oh.
Your e-mail client.
You can use an API to a service provider.
A secure link there,
the service provider may send it.
The same may apply to an SMS.
You may have a central SMS sending server
in the organization.
It can be a part of the application and
can be an API to an outside resource.
These are type of situations that come up.
You want to maintain data,
you can maintain it in an XML file,
text file, you can keep it in a database,
which is local, SQLite,
or you can have a remote database.
The various where you assign
responsibilities when we talk about
allocation of responsibilities as an
architectural design decision,
this is what we talk about.
Then we said there's something called the
coordination model.
What does the coordination model entail?
A coordination model tells us how various
elements of the system will coordinate
and synchronize.
What will be the method of communication?
Will you keep the data into a folder and
it will be picked up?
Will you have soap based communication,
HTTP?
whether you'll be synchronous or in
synchronous message passing.
Like, how do you assure timeliness?
Will you get a confirmation for each
message that goes across and resend or
you send and forget?
How do you maintain consistency?
Do you keep track of statefulness?
Is it stateless or stateful?
How do you maintain a session?
So these type of decisions, again,
an architect needs to take.
Then we come to data model.
What do you mean by data model?
What is the purpose?
You create data abstractions.
What are the units of data that have to
maintain?
All the data abstractions you decide,
do you design the metadata?
Metadata is data about data.
What type of field is it?
If you define the date field,
which type of date?
How will you record it?
Whether you record it as a string or you
record it as a date?
How will you organise it?
The organisation of data where it will be
kept remote, local, distributed.
And the entire life cycle of data,
where it will be created,
where it will be stored,
how it will be analyzed.
What part of the data will persist?
How will it be accessed by various?
So these are things about data that the
architect needs to take. You may say,
thank God, you're talking about all this.
Then do you mean the data,
an architect should do everything? Oh, no,
he's assisted by experts.
He's a technical lead.
who understands a bit of everything,
and sometimes he understands a hell of a
lot of everything.
That's up to how much you can sharpen
yourself. And then you bring in experts,
and you know enough to be able to have a
meaningful dialogue with experts.
Then we talk about mapping among
architectural elements.
You assign code modules to runtime
components, after all.
The whole job of a software developer is
creating runtime elements,
which will be used during runtime.
And at design time, you think of code,
this will be done, where it'll be done,
in which element it'll be done.
What type of hardware will you use?
Which data structure will you attach to
which code?
And in object-oriented programming,
all code is written around data
structures.
So you create an object which emulates a
data structure.
It may have a replica in a database to
create a class based on that,
and you write code around it. And then
How do you physically store these
elements? Do they load at runtime?
Are they running in the background?
These type of decisions need to be taken.
Then another important thing we talked
about was binding time decision.
Exactly when does one component know that
they'll be talking to another component?
Just like human relationships.
When do you come to know at what stage
you'll be attached to a faculty?
When you register for the course? No.
Can you register for your degree program?
No.
Can you attend the class? No,
it's a bit before that.
So...
But how is it done? No,
you are never assigned to a faculty.
You are assigned to a course,
faculty is assigned to a course,
because of the course you get assigned to
the faculty. Okay,
that's the way BIT has decided to bind
you to the faculty. Similarly,
to bind components to one another,
hardware components, software components.
They may bind during the design time,
at the time of when you compile the code,
when you design the code,
or during runtime.
On runtime, also,
by virtue of running on a common system,
or by virtue of...
Look up.
finding you have systems which help you
with service discoveries.
So you go to a service discovery,
discover the service, get access to it,
connect and go ahead. Okay.
Then we talked about choice of technology.
So, when you talk about technology,
what tools will be used?
Which framework are you going to use?
Are you going to work with a data.
NET framework? If you're working on AI,
which from framework is suitable?
Somebody.
So.
Deepa, if you are listening,
you got accidentally unmuted.
So take care.
Something private may leak out.
Okay.
Yeah.
In the olden days,
you used to have wardrobe malfunctions.
Nowadays, you've got unmute malfunctions.
They can be very embarrassing sometimes.
The other day,
I had one of my students who accidentally
switched on the...
The camera, and...
I don't think I've allowed cameras to you
all today, but I often allow cameras.
And you had the lady walking around the
mall and walking to a bus and try to...
Then.
We got a quick glimpse,
which I quickly managed to locate and
switch off a camera.
So you've got to be a little careful
about your cameras and mobiles and your
lifetime is going to be totally on
cameras and mobiles. Now,
you can't step out of your house and
reach a friend's place without getting
photographed 100 times.
So.
What about...
If I ask you,
how does choice of technology affect
testability? Okay, testability. Okay,
I want choice of technology and its
impact on testability.
So think of it as an examination question.
Okay. So you say, sir,
but you've not taught it to us. Okay,
I've not taught it to you.
You've got to imagine these situations.
because these are the type of questions
that can actually come.
So what happens is that...
Your regression testing is there. So,
do you have you provided for the correct
tools and frameworks that will support
regression testing? So,
if those frameworks or the tools you have
selected.
The support.
Rehance vs. similarity.
People.
Again.
I know this is deliberate or a
malfunction.
Okay, the civility.
I think it was a, but I did not hear it.
You can repeat it if you like.
If you actually say it for everyone.
Yeah.
Or is it a malfunction again? OK,
I think I have to mute you then.
I, I, I.
Yeah.
So that's it, you know,
you've got to be very careful about these
things. And I can't keep you muted,
everybody muted before to help you with
your privacy and security.
I think there's a great lesson on
security, you know. How do you have a,
how do you secure MS TEAMS so that you
don't
accidentally secret,
decode company and personal secrets.
So this is a security concern.
Maybe you need to design architecture for
that.
So, OK, let's...
So.
You got to have software, we can do it,
we can have frameworks which will support.
Uh...
The.
This is an event.
So...
No, when you choose technology,
you might also like to evaluate the
team's expertise, like...
Okay,
company says they're not going to develop
in Java, we are shifting to C.
and you've got a tight timeline and your
team is absolutely comfortable with Java
but hasn't worked on C#.
We appreciate that. The client says, oh,
there's not much of a difference. Yes,
we understand not much of a difference,
but when you're working this timeline,
it's going to be a bit of an issue.
So you might.
Give it a thought as to whether you will
shift your...
Choice of technology based on.
This type of input or not?
Okay, so this was a little bit of review.
We'll keep doing some reviews a little
later.
Today I want to cover another related
topic since I told you that the slide set
is limited.
I want to talk about your assignment that
is coming up.
And...
The assignment handout will be uploaded
on text in a few days.
Am I changing the slides?
Actually, yeah, who?
Hi, RAJ.
What has happened is that you probably
joined late.
I told you that I've uploaded the slides.
I've started them off.
There is a provision for you to go
forward, backward, look at the slides.
I decided to review some items from a
previous session, and I said that
But since today's session is lighter,
I'm going to do a little bit of review
work.
And I wanted you to understand design
decisions.
So I spent a few minutes reviewing design
decisions from quality.
RAJ, are you okay? Yeah, yeah, yeah. So,
yeah, so that's why,
Okay, sir, sorry. Yeah, yeah, got it, sir.
Thank you.
but the slides are there because some
people get bored with revision.
They know that stuff so well.
So the slides are there.
You can read through them in advance.
Okay. You know that in my slides,
Mhm.
Okay.
you can go forward and all that.
You are aware of it, you know?
Yeah.
You've tried that out.
Yes, I thought it's the same for all.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's simple for everybody.
Everybody can go forward. No, no, no,
No, no, we can change it.
not everybody.
There are different faculty people.
They have different choice of technology.
There are many people who prefer to do
Mhm.
screen sharing. If you do screen sharing,
then the students cannot move the slides
forward and backward.
Have you tried it in other classes?
It works in all classes.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay,
then all your teachers are probably using
the same thing. I use embedded slide view.
The only disadvantage here is that any
annotation I do,
you have to go to the video to see it.
Yeah.
You can't see it on the slide. Okay.
Ohh.
Okay, fine, got it, got it, sir, got it.
even even in the video we are not able to
see those annotations
Yeah, yeah.
On the video, videos,
you don't see the annotation.
That's very funny.
Why should the annotation not come in the
video?
Really,
this is something that I have to study.
I thought the video was getting it.
So if I draw a line here,
the video has gone without the line.
Yeah, that's what was my observation,
actually.
Now, we can see the lines.
Okay, I...
Video icons.
Okay,
what I'll do is I've made these lines
here and after the class I'll go back to
the video. At what time is this?
846 and I'll see whether these lines
appear or not.
So because I was under the belief that in
the video they appear.
Okay.
So, you know,
I'm having you stuck at this particular
slide because we've covered architecture
and significant requirements somewhat
last time. We talked about them.
We'll go through them again.
But I want to talk about the assignment.
So, again, holding you on for a while.
The handout is not available to you.
It will be available to you in a few days.
The assignment gets activated, I think,
on 27th of this month.
Let me see when is it. Yeah, 27th August.
So you have to upload assignment one
between 27 August and September 7.
So if you give yourself a holiday on
Teacher's Day or something,
you should do it before the 5th,
because you shouldn't have to come to me
telling me that, you know,
you had a technology problem and there
was a glitch and Taxila broke down.
Amazon was not accepting uploads only for
you.
So be careful.
And my friends in Switzerland,
let me warn you,
I have this problem whenever I am abroad.
I forget that the deadline in India is
already over.
I wonder whether...
Will you be still on the?
In the class or not?
Ohh.
OK, so.
You'll get the assignment in a few days,
but let me tell you about the assignment.
The learning objective is applying
software architecture basics and
architectural tactics in a real world.
Workplace context.
That will be the learning objective. Also,
analysing and designing software
architecture diagrams for domain specific
systems.
So most of the diagram looking up you
have to do on the net,
but we don't want any advanced diagrams.
Just sketches will do.
You don't have to spend your lifetime
drawing diagrams.
Just some sketches here and there.
Then the core concept is that you are
supposed to cover in this assignment is
the basics of software architecture,
tactics,
architectural significant requirement,
and you should be able to draw some
architectural views and diagrams.
What is the scope and constraints?
The system identified must be an existing
system from the student's workplace. Now,
whether you are working on that system or
not doesn't matter. For all like care,
it could be a HR system on which we
interact.
or it may be a leave application system.
Take any system that.
belongs to your workplace and you don't
have to share architectural.
descriptions of the system which will
violate your client privileges. Okay,
so it's a course which is at a very basic
level, so...
You just share what anybody in the world
should be able to know about that system.
So don't come back to me saying, you know,
this is protected by an agreement by the
client. I cannot share information.
Don't give the name of the system if you
don't have to. You don't have to say it.
Attendance system for Microsoft.
Attendance system.
The whole world is working on an
attendance system.
So what can be so confidential about
attendance?
indicate that an organisation to be used
by an organisation with 150,000 employees.
Okay, fine. There's so many of them.
So the student must identify an existing
system from the student's workplace.
Submission must follow the specific.
PPT structure and be exported as a PDF
file.
Then the task to be done.
Using an existing software system from
your workplace as context,
perform the following tasks.
System context and requirement define.
Define the goals, define the purpose,
and key functional and non-functional
requirements. Okay,
this is the goal of the system,
the functional requirements,
these are non-functional requirements.
I have seen a situation in a company,
a very large company,
where they had an appraisal system and
the appraisal system had a last date,
say 30th of June,
where all appraisals had to be submitted.
And on 30th of June,
the system used to come to a halt.
People just could not.
Post the appraisals.
So...
performance issue, availability issue.
So that sort of thing.
Then ASRs and tactics,
build a utility tree for architecturally
significant requirements.
We'll do that today.
and document the tactics used to achieve
the top five ASRs.
So for the top five ASRs,
which tactics do you think are suitable?
We'll spend more time in the,
maybe today's class, we find time,
but in future classes to try to
understand tactics a little more.
The tactics were done in CS2, CS3,
but I'll be just reviewing important
points,
like I reviewed design decisions today.
Then you have to draw diagrams.
Any 4 diagrams you are required to draw,
context diagram, module decomposition,
component and connector, deployment,
anything.
There's 4 slides with four diagrams.
Just submit them.
Use Google to find out how they can be
drawn. Maybe you can use Gemini to
Draw them for you, so, but only thing is,
make sure you sketch them yourself and
you understand them.
Then we have described how the system
works and evaluation.
This is a five marks assignment,
very small, again,
not really worth putting in too much time
into, but put in your brains,
do it quickly.
Clearly identify the existing system from
your workplace with sufficient context.
So there will be one mark for that.
Then correctly apply architectural
concepts via.
The utility tree indicating the top five
tactics and four diagrams, 2 marks.
Evaluate system requirements and describe
how components interact.
To solve the domain problem, one mark.
articulate key learnings and operational
limitations within the workplace context,
one month, five months done.
So this assignment will be uploaded.
You can hear my recording once or twice
to be very clear what it is.
If you want to ask any question about it
now, you may.
And then we proceed with today's slides.
So I'm pausing for a minute so that
anybody who wants to discuss something
can put up his or her hand and I'll
answer.
Okay.
Bharat, the quiz closes before the class,
so during the class,
if you ask me to keep it open,
it's we've already missed the bus.
The PDF has been uploaded in Taxilat.
Abhinav, which PDF are you talking about?
Just unmute and tell me.
Sorry, I wanted to understand,
like after doing the the assignment in
slide,
I have to convert in PDF and then we have
Yes, yes,
you'll be uploading it in URMILA.
to upload it.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
The easiest way to convert to PDF is
Okay.
print to PDF.
India, sure.
Yeah, that's the easiest way to do it.
So then the PDF should be uploaded.
You know why I'm insisting on this is
that we've had problems where students'
assignments could not be evaluated
because people went and used some odd
formats for submission.
So I prefer to get the submissions in PDF.
Okay.
So, here we go.
PRABHU.
We have a lot of requirements and we find
out are you significant.
So we are talking about architecture
significant requirement, identifying them,
interviewing stakeholders.
We have something called a quality
attribute workshop,
identifying business goals.
We call that pedigree attribute
elicitation method.
And then you build a utility tree which
will be required even for your assignment.
And.
Move forward.
When an architect wants to dream up an
architecture.
OK, when you dream up an architecture,
you decide.
What you really want to get done?
You got to do everything that will
influence a decision.
Few things to be remembered about
architectural decisions are that
It is just...
Those decisions.
Let's compare it with the building.
Buildings also have architects. In fact,
I know an architect.
once was quite surprised that there were
so many vacancies for architects only to
find out that they were all solution
architects, enterprise architects,
software architects,
and all from the IT industry.
And the poor architect was actually
masters in architecture and had no clue
about any of the architecture we talk
about. So those architects.
And.
In the building line,
you have architects and you have
structural engineers.
Structural engineers come with a degree
in civil engineering.
BTech, MTech in civil engineering.
These architects come with a degree in
architecture. So,
and the job of an architect,
I'm seeing it in a lighter mood,
is to make the job of the structural
engineer difficult.
They come out with designs which are
impossible to build a structure around.
And after the structures are built.
They are designers, interior designers,
and you have got...
interior construction.
These are people who do up the walls,
the furniture,
the get up and make the place look
beautiful.
But there may be architects involved in
that job, but that is not architecture.
Architectures is what is done before the
structure is set up.
Now,
the architect in that context must know
whether the building is going to be a
hospital, a mall.
An airport.
Or amphitheater.
A stadium for football or cricket.
Going to host basketball courts or an
Olympics arena, or is it going to be?
A launch pad for the next rocket taking
off from Indian soil.
It could be a hospital, a school.
It could be a structure to hold a museum.
There's so many combinations,
a conference hall.
A studio for a musical performance with
good acoustics and good viewability of
the stage, so...
Architectures got to do that.
And it's very easy to understand that
these requirements are architecturally
significant.
Similarly.
Your architect has got to know whether
you're developing a communication system.
Is it a system for a hospital?
Is it a system for an aeroplane?
What type of criticality?
What type of availability is required?
What type of response time is acceptable?
And aeroplane takes off,
completes completes a major.
confidence of the takeoff in say 20
seconds.
So anything that responds in over a few
seconds is too slow for to handle an
airplane's takeoff.
You got to have systems that can respond
at that speed.
You can have systems for telephony. Well,
we can't afford to be hearing the voice.
Being transformed into packets and taking
two seconds to transfer, we get confused,
so...
What type of security?
what type of usability,
all these major factors have got to be
known by the architects. So these,
the moment these factors have to be
designed before the programming can start
off.
is architecture.
Sometimes architects are smart.
They can set,
they can delay some of their
architectural decisions. They know that,
okay, with this decision,
the major decisions taken.
I can make a module decomposition and get
the work started.
Let's not hold up the resources.
The timelines are very tight,
but certain decisions regarding binding
time, I'm going to take in a week's time.
Certain technologies from which coding
need not start.
I will decide on the choice of technology.
Start off on the user interface.
Let the user interface people start
discussions with the client.
That input itself might help the
architect to develop further,
or to have a more meaningful dialogue
with the stakeholders, so...
This is.
The way it actually works.
So,
you find out there's those requirements
which will now this.
Design decision could relate to software
or hardware.
You find architecturally significant
requirements.
They are not necessarily only for the
hardware.
Though in this course we are discussing
mainly the software,
but choice of technology.
We don't go into design of hardware in
this course,
but choosing the hardware which is
already designed does become a part of
our work.
If you don't have the requirement,
you just might.
Then end up getting an *** in place of a
horse.
Because you're not very sure whether
you're going to work at a Dhobi GARG.
Or,
you're going to work in the race course,
so...
If it was,
you probably means a laundry with the
old-fashioned laundry which was done on
the riverside, so.
They normally used to use an *** to carry
the clothes.
But if you're in the racecourse.
For a competition, you need a resource.
So depend what is the requirement?
In what type of context are you going to
use this?
Is it going to be a game that children
are going to play?
Or is it a part of a real?
Oh.
Motor car,
which is going to be used in Formula One
racing.
So, somebody will say, "Ohh, no,
game software is also as sophisticated,
you know,
it responds as well as the software which
is installed in the car with the
architect has to decide what he'll spend
on which one, so..."
The overall structure of the system,
that means the modules that will be there,
the components,
how they will be connected,
how they interact with each other.
Once you know the ESRs,
you can take a clear-cut decision on that.
And even when you have the requirements.
We have to classify these requirements as
critical.
Important, useful.
May do, could do, should do.
Would be nice in whichever way you would
like to categorize, you can categorise it.
And...
Many of the features, which are just...
If they're not done, don't matter.
Don't even focus on them. So.
What do these?
How do you come to know?
that a particular requirement is
significant or not.
First one is...
Does this feature?
Present a technical risk.
What is a technical risk?
Many of you,
particularly the people who have been
working for a long time.
would have heard of something called
technical debt.
Let me type it out, less aec.
Any of you have suffered because of
technical debt?
Yes, I think so.
So we have created the technical depth
Ohh.
PBIs,
which are kind of purely technical in
nature,
and it has nothing to do with the
business requirement. For example,
we have pending.NET upgrades.
Lick.
some legacy things are there which needs
to be good done or we have architectural
change we have to do based on the latest.
For example,
Mm.
we want to go to microservices space
architecture or something like that.
So we put it on a technical depth and we
take it as a separately.
Yeah.
Okay,
the worst technical debts are the ones
which you have hidden from your wife.
You know, sometimes to maintain targets,
you leave some work undone.
It.
You know that, okay, stuff will work.
I will handle this work a little later.
Okay, so it's like financial debts.
You know,
you owe money to people because you
wanted to take care of your present tense.
You want to take care of your present
tense, and uh,
I'm talking to Shir Shir RAKESH Chalasia,
right?
Hello?
Who am I speaking to?
It was SATPRIT.
Who is it?
SATPRIT here, SATPRIT.
Oh, centuries, okay, okay,
so I've got shares, Mike was unmuted,
so I thought it was.
Okay.
Okay,
just mention your name before you talk.
It helps. Okay. So, SATPRIT,
what happens is that...
The worst type of deaths are the ones.
Which?
You take some loan thinking it will help
you to take care of your present tense.
And...
It basically puts pressure on your future.
And a number of technical deaths of that
kind.
Some of these deaths are officially taken.
Okay, let's do this.
We'll handle this later. But
You have to.
pay out of your future time.
You believe you will get time to do it
later,
and you don't get time to do it later.
And these represent.
It's a hidden technical risk.
Because...
Yes, sir, and I, I,
I think eighty-ninety percent of
That.
Yeah.
technical devs are never getting them,
means we never get time for those.
That's my experience.
Yeah, yeah,
and it can be a major source of problems,
because ultimately, you know, in fact...
Of late is become very fashionable or
requirement to have a lot of security
audits, because...
The thieves have caught up and they are
really wrecking havoc all over the place.
And with the AI tools being available to
them,
they are being able to really mess up
people's systems over their target.
And as a result,
you're having to take care of things.
And if your systems are not robust,
Anything that you try to do in a hurry,
try to do slipshot, try to push.
the NT to get work done.
maybe on schedule,
but taking to tighter schedule,
not providing for the risk,
the security assessments and
rectifications thereof,
they're creating problems today.
And as I mentioned last time,
financial banking,
setups,
they are facing it more than other people.
And whichever bank you're banking with,
and many of you I'm sure are working with
banks,
is there anybody here from a bank who
will share some perspective with us?
Normally we have a lot of bankers in the
class.
Last semester,
I had people working from all over the
world.
In.
Okay.
Bankers don't want to tell us they are
bankers maybe.
So it's difficult to believe in such a
big class we don't have some bankers or
some people working on banking or
financial software.
It's sometimes nice to get some
first-hand.
Case references.
Is this anybody?
It would be nice if we can share
something. OK, so...
Yeah, here you are.
Okay.
SAURAV has talked about passwords.
In fact,
passwords have become a major issue today.
All security requirements,
they say that you must use a secure vault
for passwords.
You cannot include passwords in code.
In fact,
even earlier we used to keep passwords in
XML files there.
That is no longer acceptable.
The least you have to do is put it into
the Windows registry and access it from
the registry and use it.
and you got to have a secure Windows
environment. So,
and what does KAUSIK PAUL tell us?
Point-to-point integration between two
systems,
assuming they will have the same some
change later,
and later we need to again do it through
middleware.
Got in the middle way now.
So, Kaushik,
you're talking about middleware that you
construct or third-party middleware.
Okay.
Right.
He.
So the communication protocol may be
different. X&Y,
you had a certain communication protocol,
and between X&Y, you know,
REDDY.
you got an M.
So X should communicate with M, M with Y,
Right.
and maybe you'll have to put in some
adapters there and then take care of this.
But normally in such a case,
Very often it becomes necessary because
the middleware has got a very secure
communication mechanism with VYOM.
Right.
In fact, nowadays,
any integration with banks has become far
more sophisticated than it was even five
years earlier.
If you are integrating any of your
applications with a bank,
that itself goes through a very rigorous
audit.
And I recently had an opportunity to be
involved with one with which bank was it?
But either HDFC or HSBC.
And the bank had an audit process.
And we had to clear that audit process
before they allowed us to go live.
And they gave us a test channel,
a complete audit was run on this test
channel.
They tested the middleware at our place,
whether it was communicating. And then
You've only allowed to communicate with
the middleware.
So.
People are in their own ways trying to...
Do things better and better. OK, so...
Yes.
Then again, you know,
in the same environment with the same
architect.
The architecture may change.
Because it just depends on who.
has influence in the client environment.
Every quality attribute is important,
but there are some stakeholders.
who have more see and you have to accept
the see in an organization.
As an architect,
you try to educate even the key
stakeholders.
Just because they are very powerful
doesn't mean that they are talking about
the correct stuff. So as an architect,
it's your duty to let them know what
you're prioritizing,
why you're prioritizing,
and without sounding as if you are trying
to educate them.
You've got to sound as if you're just
communicating facts and get those facts
across to the key stakeholders so that
they allow decisions to be taken with the
correct priorities.
Then if there's a requirement that is
unique,
you've never seen such a requirement.
Suddenly there's a requirement and the
client says that, you know,
If a person is transacting again,
say a person is making a payment on a
payment gateway.
ANAND.
If you don't return to your parent site.
an update doesn't immediately take place.
So there are various tactics that may be
deployed.
One is there could be a background
process which keeps checking up whether
the bank has okayed a particular
transaction ID or not. If it has,
you update it internally.
Some companies would have a manual
process.
They have some people sitting on a help
desk who keep checking up and finding out
the transaction, the bank,
which are not updated in our internal
system. So they go around updating this.
So.
Today, the client decides that, no,
this is not important.
We don't need to have a background
process. We don't need to think.
But if the same person...
Logs in.
for to the system again,
the first thing we should do is...
Cheque up whether there any payments he
has made which are yet to be updated in
the which have been cleared by the bank,
but we have not updated the system.
So we update it.
And at the end of the day,
or every two hours,
we run a system which will do a checkup.
That could be one method so that people
don't end up making a double payment.
Maybe on the payment gateway,
on entry to the payment gateway,
the previous payments are checked up to
confirm whether they've already been
transacted by the bank.
If they are,
it tells a person that this system,
this payment has already been transacted.
Maybe it's a unique requirement. Now,
if you're going to do this,
you want to cheque out whether the bank
will support a query. Earlier days,
banks didn't used to support such queries.
Today, every bank supports these queries.
Like you can query by your transaction ID
to find out whether the bank has okayed
the transaction or not.
So.
But five years back or 10 years back,
this may have been a unique requirement.
So then you will have,
you'll need to cheque up and address it
by maybe if you think it's important,
you may not take the services of a bank
which doesn't support it.
You might go to some other bank.
So.
then we need to find out if there are
certain service level agreements that are
going to be involved.
The software which is being delivered has
got a SLA with its customers.
assuring a particular level of service.
This could be an important requirement
attending to make sure that on that
dimension,
the quality of service does not suffer.
If a similar requirements in previous
projects has cost budget overruns,
because...
Clients understand their requirements
only after it's implemented,
or implementing it with the various
actors involved becomes difficult,
then we...
that such a requirement could be
considered as architecturally significant.
So normally any requirement relating to
future scalability, the client says that,
okay, today it's so much,
but gradually usage is going to increase.
So this could be architecturally
significant because you might like to
design an architecture which doesn't cost
too much today, but it has a scope for.
Growing.
Security.
Almost anything on security,
any major security.
requirement could be architecturally
significant because you'd like to design
your system to handle it.
Anything to do with availability,
if you want very high availability,
you'll probably have to go for mirroring.
You might have to go for warm restart.
You might have to go for fallback systems.
So
that would be architecturally significant
because your system will have to be
designed for that.
So.
At this stage.
Let's take a short break.
We'll take a 10 minutes break and get
back.
So if there's anything that you remember
that you would like to pick up,
and those of you who are not in a mood
for a break,
you can go ahead and watch future slides.
The remaining slides are visible.
So please go right ahead. Okay.
Oh, hi, GURURAJ.
Hi, sir.
Can you tell me how to do that?
I'd love to do it.
I think when you,
where you enable recording,
you could see that. No, I'm not sure.
No, there's no button there. No,
there's no button there.
Oh, okay.
The record transcribed.
It says stop recording,
stop transcription, show transcription.
They are the only options.
Oh, okay, then, then no problem.
Oh no,
and they don't want like us to divide it
into two parts.
I could have totally stopped it and
started again.
Then this will become two recordings.
Okay, okay.
So,
but that's why I announced that I'm
taking a break, so...
Normally people who are listening,
they know it's 10 minutes,
they'll forward it by 10 minutes and hear
it, I guess.
Ohh.
Yeah,
this is good since we've discussed it
though, like same people can.
Abhinav, yes,
we'll we'll give this feedback to
Microsoft, yeah.
They probably don't care about this tech
stakeholder.
They called HS JABBAL and his team of
architecture students. That is all right.
OK.
No, but one thing I found, you know,
with these companies, Google, Microsoft.
You wish something and sometimes I think
within a year it will happen and you'll
end up happening in three months.
They seem to keep listening to us.
I don't know whether they've got AI
listening to the recordings.
So, you know, it happens. Okay,
let's move on now. Because if I get time,
I'll do some more revisions.
So quality attributes, I like to revise,
you know, whenever I get time.
That's why today I took up the revision
in the beginning of the design decisions.
Because I find people stick a bit
confused about design decisions.
They try to read it.
They find it very boring.
They skip over it. So I thought,
let me just remind people that design
decisions are important roles of the
architect. Okay.
The drivers,
they are the key factors that influence
identification and prioritisation of
these requirements.
Now, business goals.
is very important that if you are an
architect, first you try to figure out.
What business client is it?
and what the client would really be
looking for.
What they make money out of?
Then...
You must get in touch with the
stakeholders.
And get a good idea as to.
what the stakeholders give priority to,
what they consider important.
So you must have meetings with the
stakeholders.
What they talk about convert them into
raw quality attribute.
Language, okay. Basically,
person is talking about performance,
availability, usability.
Particularly if you're working with
medical systems.
Sometimes, the hotels.
There are statutory.
requirements by the law of the land or by
regulatory authorities.
If you're working for...
These TPS,
third party administrators for hospitals.
They have a regulatory body.
If you're working on insurance systems,
there's again a regulatory body.
If you're working on shares, mutual funds,
regulatory bodies are there.
They have statutory reporting formats.
They have reporting frequencies,
disclosures.
So your system has got to handle that.
They have.
certain confidentiality requirements.
Then all this said and done,
when an architect gets down to work.
like cost and budget constraints.
And sometimes we have to simply tell the
client, well, this budget,
these requirements, they're not happening.
And the famous triangle we talk about in
project management.
Coop.
Time.
Cost.
Knock out any one of the three,
everything is doable.
Just run it in your mind.
Knock out one of these three.
All projects are doable.
You specify all three.
Sometimes you have to simply tell the
client, sorry, Pan,
this project isn't happening.
Allow me to change one of them.
So the client says, no, my cost is fixed.
I cannot spend more than 10 million.
My time is fixed, maximum one year.
Okay,
then I'll let you know what I can do for
that.
If you don't like it, find someone else,
but this is what I can do.
Fixes the scope, fixes the time,
and say you,
I'll give you a quotation if you can't
get it done.
Threw me up, hit someone else.
You told me the cost,
you told me the scope.
Maybe I'll never be able to do it.
Maybe instead of one year,
you give me five years.
Whenever I have spare manpower,
there's no other work to do.
I'll plug in your job and get it done.
So cost budget constraints are important,
time to market.
Very often, software with bugs,
with deficiencies are put to market
because the one who's first.
Hold on.
you take the market.
Another thing about time to market is...
That.
The person who's earlier to market starts
getting a return on investment early.
In fact,
this is one of the key features of agile
development.
When you follow a process like Scrum,
you prioritise your artifacts.
You take your backlog,
take the priority items.
Create a deliverable.
Package, deliver it at an early date,
you start getting return on investment,
so...
Architectures also is panned out in such
a way that important items should get
delivered quickly to get your returns.
Then.
There's some simple.
Functional requirements,
which are easy to deliver.
Some of them may not be very
straightforward. Detect fraud,
suspected fraud should be.
Then non-functional requirements,
easy to customize, modifiability.
may not be straightforward.
They should work under heavy load.
Availability in different situations.
Or even the case of hardware failure,
they should continue to work.
Then.
Scalability.
Like YouTube, Netflix, the design.
the system in such a way that even with
increasing load,
it doesn't create a problem.
Then there are regulatory requirements
for storing and transcribing health
records.
In fact, uh...
Even a doctor working in the hospital.
Accessing a patient's records who's not
currently.
You get in it too is.
deviation. So it gets flagged.
The systems,
hospital systems automatically flag it,
bring it up to the concerned authority
and take it up with the doctor.
or the doctor to explain why it happened.
So any of these requirements which appear
challenging,
the first one being simple functional
requirement, they are architectural.
Sometimes even functional requirements
can become architecturally significant.
Maintain an audit trail, send alerts.
variety of data entry mechanism. In fact,
nowadays, it's gone absolutely crazy,
the data entry mechanism. For example,
MS TEAMS.
If you want to set a quiz in MS TEAMS,
earlier we had to copy paste.
The best that was possible it could pick
up from a PDF file.
That also not properly,
you have to edit it now.
Who got Mister Copilot?
Just give the questions there and it'll
arrange them properly,
make sure they are done in proper order.
In fact, if you give the topic,
you give a little bit of context,
it can even make the questions for you.
TOM.
Audit trail,
whether it should be in a file or a
database.
Third party interaction.
communication mechanism.
Just now we talked about communication
between X, Y, then you are the mediator,
the impact.
what communication mechanism I use,
notification,
whether you're going to use SMS, e-mail,
or...
App-based people who have an app can get
a thing or a message queue, how you will.
So, here we've got a lot of drivers.
safety, effective flow, smooth operations,
environment.
Various drivers,
what requirements are set?
So, from the requirement documents,
you can come to know.
That design decisions, which...
come down to you.
From that you come to identify why these
design decisions are taken,
the other ASRs, business goals,
business has got certain clear-cut goals.
That will help you to discover ESRs,
discussion with stakeholders, meetings,
brainstorming,
and construction of a utility tree,
again with stakeholders.
So I talked about this sometime back.
Must should could would.
So when you make a user story.
Must and should.
You look for them and try to see whether
they give you any direction towards
Architectures requirement.
You've got the...
Software Engine Book of Knowledge.
From the Project Management Institute.
So,
it tell you how to do requirement
capturing exercises.
It includes quality interviews,
so you can follow the processes there.
Your basic skill requirements.
Good.
With explicit requirements on high
usability, system modularity,
performance through resilience,
fault detections, so...
If any of these are identified,
you put them as architecturally
significant.
So,
if the in the absence of basics school
requirements not reflecting the quality
attribute clearly.
It can be a challenge for the architects
to extract the ESR. However,
this makes up the...
Role of the architect even more complex,
so architect has to somehow find out.
So when you have designed decisions,
you come to know allocation of
responsibilities, coordination model,
data model.
Management of resources,
mapping among architectural thing,
finding choice of technology. So,
when you look at this...
decisions which are taken in the past.
You can find out the decisions and then
again take decisions based on that.
So past decisions sometimes give you an
indicator.
You have something called a quality
attribute workshop.
which you involve the stakeholders.
Who are the stakeholders?
Sometimes the stakeholders may not be in
person. They are just a law.
Somebody who's expert in law can sit in
the meeting.
So...
In the beginning, you introduce.
The what are the?
who are the people involved,
what is the role in the organization,
what is the relation of the system is
informed to everybody.
You call everybody in the workshop,
everybody is introduced,
and what they are representing.
That itself gives other people an idea of
other perspectives. You know,
A big problem with stakeholders is
sometimes they don't realise that there
are other perspectives,
there are other ways to look at things.
So when they see all those people sitting
in one room, they realize, you know,
we are not the only people for whom the
system is being developed.
These people are also there.
Then some key stakeholder,
a representative of the chief executive
or some sort of a strategic decision
maker.
States the business mission. Let's say,
listen folks,
though all of you have your concerns,
we are addressing certain missions in the
organization. This is the reason.
why we are going to have this software
being developed.
So let's not talk about any other agenda.
We've got to,
this is something we've got to achieve.
Then the architect gives an overall
presentation. Let's see, this is what...
the system architecture stands for.
This is what we have got in place.
And as far as what you all are interested
in, this is what it achieves.
The current status.
What is the type of security you've got?
What is the type of maintainability,
testability?
What is the type of availability?
What is the best availability that is
possible in the current system?
What type of performance is achieved?
Let people know very clearly what your
current system is.
And then?
You list the drivers.
Let's see, listen in this architecture.
This is the other key things that we have
considered now.
Ask the stakeholders that you can try to
understand what we have given you,
anything additional you feel should be
addressed.
Please indicate if you think the software
is unnecessarily addressing certain
issues, please let us know.
Any correction you feel out of the
experience of the system,
something is not being attended properly,
please bring it up.
So.
When people bring this up.
A consensus starts building because
they're doing it in public view.
They're not privately telling you things.
In fact,
very many people keep quiet and plan to
come and tell you something privately.
But the more you discuss it publicly,
the better. What comes up privately,
later you can factor it in and take it up
in a future presentation.
Then you have brain throbbing.
Let it's they may give it to you in cards;
you might have given some cards to the.
people, they've submitted the cards. Now,
based on the cards.
The.
The facilitators drop the scenarios in
that typical way, source of stimulus,
stimulus, artifact, response,
measurement in an environment.
So the facilitators draw these diagrams
and give it, present them on the screen.
And they ask the stakeholder who has
presented this situation,
and probably they sit for the stakeholder
and help the stakeholder make this right.
Let's see,
we want to understand what you're talking
about. So here is a scenario.
So is this what you're trying to say?
And then eventually the stakeholder says,
no, actually, probably not.
important packet packet.
Or you haven't understood it clearly,
this is the type of measure that we need
to achieve. Okay,
we've got that type of measure.
After all the stakeholders have made
their presentations,
they have explained their points to the
public, everybody has understood,
we consolidated them.
If you want to list that, okay,
these are the scenarios that have been
presented by the group.
Is there anybody else giving anything
else or this is final?
Having done it.
Each stakeholder is given a number of
votes.
And in such a way that a stakeholder
cannot vote for more than 30% of the
total scenarios.
So if there are 20 scenarios that have
come up, each person is given six votes.
So you vote the scenarios which you think
are important. According to you,
they are the top most priorities.
So here people have heard everybody else
out.
They may have realised by now that what
they are saying is probably not the most
important thing.
They'll give the votes to someone else.
And after having done that.
You have the list of priorities and in
your report,
which will present in your assignment,
you will list only the top five.
So if you can,
you can do a dummy exercise with one or
two friends of yours,
make a list and take the top five.
So, we've understood your business goals.
We've understood quality attributes.
There are some non-architectural
solutions for the business goals,
which have nothing to do with the
software architecture,
probably nothing to do with the system
itself.
And then route driven architecture.
Business goals often lead to quality
attribute requirement.
Business goals may directly affect the
architecture without participating in
quality attributes,
and some of them not influenced at all.
So.
These are examples.
The categories of business goals,
but they have to be specified very
clearly like this.
Growth, we want the company to grow.
How much?
We want to bring the market share to 15%.
Currently, it's 10%.
Meeting financial objectives,
30% profit after tax is required.
Then we'll try to figure out what we are
trying to do.
Is it some way going to help to achieve
that profit?
learn, meet personal objectives,
learn new technology.
By implementing this with people,
learn new technology.
So each of these questions have got to be
clearly answered.
WILP.
Meeting responsible employees,
reduce workload.
Will this system reduce the workload?
Calculate properly,
how will it reduce the workload?
Responsibility of society.
How do you metres work?
Maybe.
less carbon in the atmosphere.
responsibility of the state.
Is it compliant to the regulatory
authorities?
Maybe old architecture left out some
compliant issues.
And compliant issues may go to top
priority because you will not just get an
okay from the regulator.
You may be asked to stop doing business.
So, responsible to stakeholders.
You want to share the the division with
the with the stakeholders?
Market position.
So...
Intellectual property rights,
50 design registrations.
You want to achieve more design
registrations with the people.
Business processes,
productivity improvement,
automated test strategies.
environment factors, US dollar volatility,
US should be protected against that.
So these may be typical business goals.
I guess.
So,
government wants to speed up cashless
transactions,
so government introduces Beam.
The key things are usability. Anybody,
even the local coconut water supplier,
the coconut seller should be able to use
it.
That roadside tea shop should be able to
use it.
The auto rickshaw drivers should be able
to use it.
You have security because...
Even with such low IT knowledge users,
it should be secured.
It should not be possible to.
So these are very convenient user
interfaces they have set up.
And with these user interfaces,
it leaves very little for an M tech in
software systems or computer science to
Be involved.
They're very easy to operate,
and that was a business code.
So.
Final business goal presentation.
Subject.
goal object, the goal, the environment,
goal, how it is measured,
and what is the values of these goals.
So this entire process you should be able
to take care of to understand the
business goals. You present,
make a presentation business goals,
you got to bring this up very clearly.
Then,
with these business goals to capture the
business goals,
we have another process called the
Pedigree Attribute Elicitation Method.
Again, how does it start?
Firstly, you give an overview of TANVI.
why we are having it,
what we hope to achieve. Then you make a,
the management makes a presentation of
the business drivers.
You've seen on the previous page,
you can read it carefully.
So everybody is given a clear indication
of what are the business drivers.
Then we have the architectural drivers.
So this service business drivers,
you've got architectural drivers.
that the architect will clearly state
that, okay, see, listen,
this is what we've been told,
drives the business,
because of which we require to satisfy
these quality attributes. And hence,
we have come to the conclusion that the
following ESRs are important based on a
quality attribute workshops also that we
have done.
Now,
there's something to do with business
goal elicitation.
That means actually finding out a
business goal.
You have categories.
You understand?
the major business goals as scenarios
that this is what is to be achieved and
this is how we explain it.
For example,
business goal to increase market share,
business goal to increase profitability,
business goal to have more retention.
And how do you intend to measure this?
So that we have understood the
presentation.
Off.
Your.
Is this?
We know what is architecturally
significant.
We try to prioritise these goals.
And.
With the help of these two,
By looking at the business goals,
what are the potential quality attributes
that we need to take up and what are the
scenarios which support that business
attribute?
And we'll understand the difference
between a scenario and a quality
attribute.
I've always been distinguishing,
but in the utility tree,
it'll become even clearer.
assignment of pedigree to existing
quality attribute drivers.
For each architectural driver named in
step three,
we identified which business goal does it
support. So you've got existing drivers,
which business goal does it support?
Why is there 40 seconds performance
requirement but not 60 millisecond or not
80 millisecond? Why 40 millisecond?
So you have to very clearly say that.
This is the competition.
This is the way these things respond.
May have done a research on psyche that
people are willing to wait for 40 seconds
to get the response, so...
Trying to...
Any explores in this will not capture the
chooser's attention.
And.
VIVEK.
Conclude this by reviewing the results,
by understanding whether we have got all
our quality attributes in place or not,
and then...
We have this utility tree,
and utility tree is something you will be
able to,
you will be required to present as a part
of assignment one.
You take the critical quality attributes
that directly influence the system.
So in the utility tree,
the first set of branches are,
what are the key quality attributes?
Could be availability, security,
Usability.
See, this is the trunk of the tree.
So it's a hierarchical representation.
This is the root.
The first level is the quality attributes.
And each quality attribute is broken into
one or more scenarios.
SINDHURA.
Source of stimulus, stimulus, artifact,
response, measure,
all the entire thing acting in a given
environment.
So.
This, for each one,
you will present a picture like this.
And this is called breaking them down
into more detailed scenarios.
So when you have a utility tree like this
on one page.
The stakeholders can try to refine the
ASRs.
They look at this and say, OK,
this is the story. OK, we understand.
The ROUT.
Call utility.
You write a utility.
measure of how will the system satisfy
the stakeholders need. So utility,
we do all this utility on a scale from
zero to 100.
So the user may say that I've achieved
80%. On each one of these.
scenarios also,
you will have to indicate that.
Utility.
branches, quality attributes,
represent key quality attributes such as
performance, security, scalability,
and liability.
That's what I've done there.
Leaf note, that's the last bottom of it.
Each quality attribute breaks down into
more specific scenarios detailing how the
system should behave under certain
conditions.
Certain condition is the environment.
How it should behave if there's so and so
stimulus, this should be the response,
and this is a measurement that is
expected.
This is what we have to give it the leaf
node.
So, here you are.
Utility tree,
this is exactly the diagram which is
expected from you as an outcome of your
assignment.
So this is the attribute, performance,
usability, underperformance.
This is hot.
Signifies.
This attribute, transaction response time,
throughput,
this is just a heading given to this
scenario. This scenario,
this is the heading.
This scenario, this is the heading.
So both these scenarios relate to the
same heading.
So it's given very clearly.
A user updates a patient's user.
Source of stimulus updates a patient's
account in response to a change of
address.
So this is the source of stimulus.
Change of address notification while the
system is under double the peak load.
That means this is the environment,
environment, source, user.
Stimulus.
Change of address notification.
Transaction complete.
This is the response,
and the measurement of responses,
4 seconds.
Pooja SHUKLA, are you?
Available?
Oh, yes, sir, I am.
Yeah. Welcome, welcome, PRAJJWAL. Oh, God.
You're very attentive.
Were you following me on this last
scenario, or should I repeat?
Yes, Sir.
Uh, yeah, okay.
I'll repeat it, I'll repeat it,
I'll repeat it.
Why I'm calling everybody's attention and
just waking up at this time,
people tend to get a bit sleepy at the
end of the class. It gets so boring.
So I thought, let's have some activity.
Yeah.
It's totally alright, sir.
So when people hear somebody else's voice,
you know, people will suddenly realize.
And since you're the last person who
communicated,
Yeah.
and there's a good chance that it would
still be attentive. So quality attributes,
Yes, sir.
we said utility tree starts with utility.
So I don't want to waste an extra column,
Yeah.
but if there's a column,
that column would have just one item
called utility.
Then we have quality attributes,
performance, usability,
and then we can continue on the next page.
Attribute refinement is this quality,
how do I put it in a few words,
different representations.
And each of these representations has got
a scenario.
And a scenario should have an environment.
So let's take the first one now.
I took the second one.
I'll take the first one.
Peak load, this is the environment, OK?
Yes, sir.
So, go to the environment.
S.
System, so the artefact is the system.
Okay.
Mm.
The environment is peak load.
DUTTA.
Source of stimulus is user.
And what is the stimulus?
Update the patient's account.
And then what is the response?
Transaction completes.
What is the measure of the response? 0.
75 seconds.
One 75 seconds, yeah.
And this is exactly what we expected to
do in real life and in the examination
conditions.
If you are trying to design a system,
you must be able to prepare statements
like this.
So you've got a whole lot of statements
here. Study them, understand them. Okay.
Yes, sir.
This is an actual practical requirement.
Let's not just muddle about it.
And for every quality attribute,
you should be able to write attribute
refinements like this.
And even if you use Gemini to do your
assignment, please understand it.
That's most important.
If doing it in Gemini helps you to
Remember,
and you'll be able to utilise in your job
later, the job is done.
And irrespective of whether you are a
solution architect,
an enterprise architect,
or not an architect at all,
tomorrow if you are expected to present a
scenario.
A scenario presented so precisely,
who's the user,
what's the source of stimulus,
on what environment,
in what environment or what artifact,
what's the response,
how you measure it sounds very impressive.
It follows that there's a principle
called SMILES or something, no?
It goes by that. Okay, now.
There is something in the alpha 2
alphabets after this.
Everywhere.
Would you like to take a guess what this
might be? Just try to take a guess.
You're into this business for the last
few years now in IT.
Very good, Abhinav. How important?
To whom now? The next question is to whom?
How feasible? Okay.
So the first one is how important to the
business, high value, low value,
or medium value?
And the second one is how significant to
the architecture.
Impact on architecture, medium impact,
high impact or low impact on architecture.
Okay.
So that you need to know that impact on
business, impact on architecture.
So we've got the rest also,
configurability, maintainability,
extensibility. You've got the thing,
and I'm sure you can read it out for
yourself at leisure.
And I request you to read all these ESRs
carefully,
because they'll help you to formulate the
ESRs for your assignment.
Thanks, PRAJJWAL. I think that was it.
I'll carry on showing the next few slides.
And if I find time at the end,
which I don't think I'll find,
I'll do a little more reviewing on
tactics.
So here it is security. Yeah.
Sir,
I have I have one I have one question,
sir, regarding the assignment,
is that going to be an individual or a
Yep.
group level?
assignments are all individual.
Both assignments in this course are going
to be individual assignments.
After the second assignments,
we are going to have group discussions
where we'll be grouping you and your
individual assignments we will discuss in
the group.
And it will be a typewritten discussion,
not a verbal discussion. Okay?
And it will be on Takshila.
Okay.
It'll be on Takshi Live.
We'll be using the discussion forum for
that.
We'll create a separate forum for each
group,
and you'll be able to see the discussion
of other forums,
but you'll be able to participate only in
discussions of your own forum.
Mm.
So that, according to me,
is one of the major educational
components of this course.
because we will pick up a lot of wisdom
from everybody.
And I expect people to do it sincerely
because knowing fully well that this is
going to be shared with your peer group,
people are more scared of peer group than
the faculty, you know. They don't,
in today's world,
it is more important that your peer group
is impressed with you than your faculty.
Faculty doesn't matter.
Somebody who comes into your life for six
months and over and done with.
But your peer group, you'll be surprised.
You'll be in touch with them even after
the course.
And the other people who recommend you,
yeah, tell me.
So.
So, the groups, the group,
the group discussion that we are going to
know later,
so how we will be having the selection
Yeah.
for group that will there be a choice of
a student or?
No, no, not your choice.
It will be selected by the system and
we'll try to balance out the years of
experience and the type of work you are
doing. We'll try to have a mixed group.
in each group. Okay. So,
so they'll be strangers,
Oh, oh, okay.
but let me assure you out of my own
experience, by the end of this course,
they'll no longer be strangers.
Yeah.
Okay,
so at least you'll pick up a few friends.
See, when you work as a group,
the mission is to complete an assignment.
Some people do it and everybody takes a
credit for it. Here,
you have individually done an assignment
and now you are presenting it to your
peer group and your peer group is getting
into judgement and they may not share all
the judgement with you.
OK,
but they form opinions about who you are.
And my request to you is,
with your peer group, form a good opinion.
Okay.
It's going to help you in life. You must,
your peer group must believe that you are
somebody.
to be taken seriously. Okay,
so when you do assignment 2,
not assignment,
and assignment 2 is mostly a continuity
of assignment one. In fact,
we allow people to continue the same
topic.
A better.
Yeah.
PRAJJWAL, no, no, no,
I think you said something.
Could not hear you calling my name. Okay,
that's perfectly not. No, he,
I don't think Ashutosh meant better for
your comment.
He was responding to what we are speaking
over here.
Okay, sir. Got it. All right.
About the grouping and all, yeah, yeah,
right. No, I understood because, yeah,
Yes, sir.
Yes, sir, better in the sense, last time.
tell me, tell me.
Yeah, sorry.
Last time we had a group selection and a
few of them were not present and not
contributing.
So it's better if we randomly select the
groups.
Yeah, but I'll tell you all the same.
There will be people who wouldn't be
bothered. For example,
we are doing this quiz and we are having
heavy participation.
And even as an assignment,
And it depends on how much you understand
the assignment. See,
my experience with teaching with BITS and
as a student of BITS,
if you have done your assignments,
whatever you do, utter nonsense, because,
you know, in assignments we do something,
you don't get very poor marks,
because faculty is basically looking to
see whether you've done something.
If you do something very impressive,
you may get full marks,
but you normally out of five, three, four,
so you will end up getting. Now,
if you land up getting three, four, three,
four in the quiz also, you make around 12.
Think of it.
You made say 6 + 3, 9, 9 + 12, 21.
You've already made 21, and with a 21,
you are not likely to get an E grade.
You'll at least get a D.
And PITS has got a comparative.
Greeting concept.
So if you have appeared for all the
assignments and the quiz,
you're already with the crowd.
And in bits,
it's more important to get the type of
marks everybody gets.
If you get left behind,
and the only reason you can get left
behind is if you somehow,
you're totally unprepared for an exam.
And in this course,
that's going to be difficult because the
attendance I'm seeing for the quizzes,
people are definitely attending,
going through this programme for 5
minutes.
They're looking at the answers of the
quizzes they've given,
even if they're using AI.
And with that level of knowledge,
I'm sure you can go and write something
in the examination only.
So if you can write something in the
examination hall,
you can pick up some marks.
So that's not a problem.
If you followed something in the class.
The thing is that you might be able to
utilise this in your work,
and that's what I give most importance to.
Okay, now there's some, oh,
there's a very elaborate message.
Shreya Chowdary,
a question regarding comprehensive
example, you're jumping the gun.
As discussed earlier,
we need to write an answer based on the
question and there's no need to separate
sheet like we did in our bachelor's, okay,
at Bombay University. For example,
if a question is given with a scenario
like suppose you are...
Designing an online banking system,
security availability, so and so.
priority, explain why they are important,
suggesting architecture tactics to
achieve them and discuss anything.
In such a case,
I will explain the scenario,
justify the selection.
Sufficient, yeah, and...
Absolutely right and indicate very
clearly which part of the question you're
answering.
Have your question in mind all the time.
Just don't digress.
In the comprehensive exam,
there's a tendency to digress because
there's so much available to you.
And you know,
people asked me last time about book and
all that. And I keep telling people,
buy a book if you're going to have the
time to read the book.
As far as reference is concerned,
slight references,
should normally be good enough in a
comprehensive exam situation.
And.
I cannot stop anybody from studying a lot,
because that is against the spirit,
because the sky is the limit.
But if you want to be an average student,
Having the slides available,
going through the slides.
I,
I would believe you can make an average
performance.
I graduated engineering in 22 and was
unemployed for two years.
I wanted to get a better understanding of
technology, so I joined this course.
Looking forward to making the best out of
it in every way possible. Great PRAJJWAL.
Great PRAJJWAL.
OK, so.
High, medium, low priority.
What is the best approach?
How much time is should do for the
project?
As in architected,
even when there's no BSR.
Are you accountable for ESR?
Interview with struggle must be planned
by you well in advance.
Utility is more like a repository
approach.
Choose the one more suited for that.
Is a time to fill, so...
So, you...
You have.
Actually,
an architect's position is actually
unenviable.
Even if the client doesn't give you the
requirement,
ultimately if the software fails,
you will be responsible.
So you've got to be a technologist.
a social worker,
a person who can interact very well,
a person who's smart, charismatic,
people feel like talking to you,
you're approachable by the client.
When you want to meet the client,
the client is more than happy sitting and
talking to you.
That's the type of person you've got to
be. And the techies,
You got to understand the language.
They should understand your instructions
or your guidance or your designs very
well.
You got to present them in a form that
can be implemented,
not like the great architect who designed
the building,
which the structural engineers don't know
how to create the structure.
That won't do.
You architect a system,
the coder should be able to code it.
Then agile,
we've touched on agile last time,
but just see the components of an agile
framework.
If there's anybody who wants me to
explain any part of it,
there's hardly a minute left,
I can review it later.
I can come back to this.
Agile against traditional agile manifesto.
This we have taken up in the previous
class.
Some, but though our time is almost out,
but I'd like to share some finding with
you again. I've done it last time.
Let me take a quick look at...
Software architecture.
Quiz 4 has just closed.
So I'm going to take a look at the result
of quiz 4.
Preview the quiz.
Sorry.
184 people have attempted Quiz 4.
And.
140 people have got between 14 and 15.
Sort of 180 people, if 140 have got.
Between 14 and 15.
Tell me,
SAMPATH whom do I increase the timer for?
So, but...
You'll have to learn how to use some AI
if you're not if you're finding the time
shot.
So, I cannot, I cannot increase the timer.
Yeah, no, I'm very happy with the cloud.
The type of interaction you'll do,
you'll make my day for me.
It's a very nice way to start a day and...
OK, SAMPATH. Thanks.
Thanks for accepting it.
No, if the performance was poor,
I would have increased that.
I think you have only your fellow
students to blame.
So with that, I'm closing.
Thank you very much.
My good wishes that you enjoy the
remaining classes and have a nice weekend.
Bye-bye.
Thank you, sir. Have a great day.
Yeah.
Thank you, sir. Have a great day.
Thank you. Great. Thanks. Thanks. Thanks.